بالاعنف منذ بدء الحرب العاصمه الاوكرانيه
هدف جديد لقصف صاروخي كبير تخللته انفجره
قويه واطلاق مكثف لصواريخ الدفاعات الجويه
11 صاروخا من نوع اسكندر بارستي بعيد
المدى اطلقت باتجاه المدينه حسب السلطات
واسقطت وفق الروايه الاوكرانيه تستطيع
منظومه الصواريخ اسكندر تدمير اهداف
معاديه ذات قيمه عاليه في العمق التكتيكي
للعدو ويمكن تزويدها برؤوس حربيه دقيقه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تحدثت من جانبها عن
تدمير اهداف عسكريه خلال قصف روسي لمطاره
اوكرانيه باسلحه قالت انها عاليه الدقه
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني استعجل في ظل هذه
التطورات تعزيز الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه وتزود بطائره اف 16 لوقف
الهجمه الروسيه على المدن الاوكرانيه على
الجبهه الشرقيه تطورات لا تقل اهميه في
بيليغرود الروسيه على
وتعرض عدد من قراها ومؤسسه صناعيه لقصف
اوكراني بعشره القذائف المدفعيه والهاون
وراى حاكمها الحل في ضمن خركيف اليها في
هذه الاخيره التي ساعدها الاوكرانيون بعد
ان بسط الرسل سيطره على اجزاء كبيره منها
في الاشهر الاولى للحرب افاد رئيس الاداره
العسكريه في المقاطعه باشتداد القصف
الروسي على قرها الحدوديه مع روسيا صوت
التصعير شمالا في كييف او شرقا في خركيف
يرافقه تكثيف ملحوظ للعمليات الروسيه في
منطقه تيدونيات وفق هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه التي اكدت صدق قواتها لتسعه
عشر هجوما على محاور عده شرقي البلاد ولا
تبدو بخموت جبهه طويت صفحتها بشكل نهائي
ففي اتجاه هذه المدينه قالت الهيئه ان
الروسا نفذوا خلال اليوم الماضي عمليات
هجوميه وصفتها بالفاشله في الاطراف
الشماليه الشرقيه للمدينه وغارات استهدفت
ايضا مدينه افديك
ورافقها قصف مدفعي خرسون تبقى ايضا مسرحا
لقصف روسي على المقاطعه بينما تحدثت سلطات
دينيبرو الاوكرانيه عن قتلى وجرحى في قصف
روسي استهدف المناطق الجنوبيه
وجنوبا في مقاطعه اوديسا افادت الاداره
العسكريه الاوكرانيه باسقاط دفاعاتها
الجويه عددا من المسيرات الروسيه الهجوميه
واعتبرت ان خطر الهجمات واسعه النطاق على
المقاطعه لا يزال قائما تقول موسكو ان
اهداف العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا لم تتغير ولابد من تحقيقها كامله
بينما تخوض هجمات متقطعه ضمن ما تصفه
بالهجوم المضاد لاستعاده اراضيها
[موسيقى]